You've heard of it, haven't you?
The legend of Sparta?
When I was young, my father would tell me stories about it.
Long ago, in ancient times, a demon rebelled against his own kind for the sake of the human race.
With his sword, he shut the portal to the demonic realm and sealed the evil entities off from our human world.
But since he was a demon himself, his power was also trapped on the other side.
I never believed it.
I thought it was just a child's fairytale.
But I discovered that this so-called legend wasn't a myth at all.
Sparta existed.
How do I know?
Well, I met the sons of Sparta.
Both of them.
Though the same blood of their father flowed through their veins, Sorry, we're gonna watch the intro every time, you guys.
They're sadists.
Going in for the brotherly hug.
It's sharper than I remember.
Just bros crossing swords.
Probably a thing every brother does.
Oh my god!
It's the strong kid.
Like, what hair gel does he use?
The rain is made of hair gel.
You think they always wanted a brother.
Oh my gosh, it's my brain rot.
I'm sorry.
I can't stop saying that.
A brother.
If you don't follow me on Twitter...
Basically, a couple months ago I learned of the Mufasa trailer and there was two lines in it.
Where he goes, I always wanted a brother.
And then he says it again.
I always wanted a brother.
Last night... Wait, hold on.
How do I stop the...
Stop it.
Oh, there we go.
Just go to load game.
I was scared for a second.
Last night I learned that it's from a song.
I learned that it's from a song in the new Mufasa movie.
But I can't stop saying it.
They say it six times.
So many times.
I'm gonna sing it in the next carry on.
The rest of the song is so cute.
And then you get to... It's like...
It sounds so Lion King.
It sounds so cute.
And then you just hit the wall and it's...
I always wanted a brother.
Just like you.
I've been like torturing my cats with it.
Like the paws.
You know, with like Butaro and everything.
I'll be like...
Hey paws, did you always want a brother?
They say that.
They just are so... I can't...
I can't stop saying it.
It comes from deep within.
I always wanted a brother.
I'm sorry.
I can't stop saying it.
I think I found a new karaoke request.
But like I said, the rest of the song is so cute.
They're like...
Hey, did your mama say you can't stay out this late?
Hey, did your father say...
I don't know the words.
I only know I always wanted a brother.
I can't stop saying it.
I wish I was home to play DMC3 too.
Have fun!
Make sure not to get a tummy ache from anger.
These voices are tough.
Thank you!
It's okay if I have tummy ache.
I have tummy medicine.
Minto is a 45 year old single mom who's single-handedly funding Mufasa's box office.
I haven't even gone and seen it.
What are you talking about?
Thank you so much for the 50 gifted thank you!
Oh, because we were watching the intro I forgot to say...
My throat is a little hoarse today.
That was supposed to be me neighing because it's a hoarse.
Hopefully it will be okay for tomorrow.
Merry Mintmas!
Have some gifts!
Thank you, Solidus!
I'm sure you guys can tell a little bit.
How did a horse get in here?
A little horse.
Oh, Solidus!
Thank you for the 20 gifts!
Thank you!
Also, I was thinking earlier.
I was like, man...
I wish there was something I could wear on my head for Devil May Cry.
Like I get to wear the headband for Metal Gear.
I was like, I wish there was something I could wear on my head.
Like, you know, Dante doesn't really have anything and I don't have a coat or anything to wear.
But then I was like, wait, watch this.
Watch my face, watch my face, watch my face, watch my face.
Seriously?
Thanks for the 10 gifted!
Watch, watch, watch, watch.
I, I can have emo bangs!
I can have emo bangs when I play!
It's so perfect!
Yeah, I'm emo.
Oh, not a phase.
Oh, what was that song that Fauna and Mume came out with recently?
So good.
Watch Transformers 1 instead.
Same plot, but better in every way.
Please, Minky, I'm going to pass away.
Doomed robot.
I don't know the last time I've been to the movie theater.
But everybody was talking about the Transformers movie.
How good it was.
At least from what I saw on my timeline.
And everybody's now talking about Sonic 3, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Apparently that was very good.
Speaking of movies, I saw Sonic 3 on Thursday.
It was so good I cried in the theater.
My childhood has officially been made and I can't believe it.
Oh gosh, Sonic fans.
Sonic fans have been through it.
You guys started so strong.
It was so cool to be a Sonic fan back in the day.
And then it hit the lowest point.
It was so bad and everything was just so low.
How do we recover from here?
But then, you rose up.
Sonic fans, Sonic fandom rose up.
It's so good.
It's now cool to like Sonic again.
Thank you for the 30 gifted.
Minto, if your soul becomes a devil arm slash weapon for Dante or some other devil hunter to use, what would it be?
Probably like...
You do the Moe Moe Q.
You make the heart with your hands and it shoots like a real Moe Moe beam.
And it's just ultra powerful.
Probably.
I don't have a lot, but here's a small Mintimus present.
Thank you!
Known for BS.
Thank you for the pink.
Gotta get prepped for Christmas plus also work tonight going into the morning.
Here's a small gift for Christmas.
Huge props for the amazing year you've had and here's to an even better 2025.
Thank you!
Thank you for the 10 gifted also.
Oh my gosh, you guys are sending so much.
Thank you!
I'll be celebrating Christmas on the 24th.
Let's go!
Merry Christmas.
Happy holidays everybody.
Thanks for the 5 gifted.
Merry Chrysler.
Well then I'll be doing karaoke.
I feel like I mostly celebrate Christmas on Christmas Eve too.
I feel like, you know...
I feel like that's how I do things also.
Sorry Minto, she doesn't need to wear anything because her hair is already white like Dante.
And also emo.
Do it to avoid traffic.
No, I don't know what it is.
I feel like...
Christmas feels like one of those holidays where the lead up is more exciting than the actual day.
Or maybe I feel that way as an adult.
But as a kid obviously Christmas day was like so awesome.
But there's also just that fun anticipation.
Even as a kid being like...
Every day like...
You know, you're just kind of...
And then the day comes and it all happens in a flash and then it's over.
But the anticipation is really I feel what makes it so exciting and so much fun.
Maybe.
Back when Santa was real.
He's still real.
He is real.
What are you talking about?
That's just most seasonal holidays I feel.
The month leading up to Halloween is better than the day itself I think.
I was going to include Halloween also but actually...
I like Halloween so much still.
Even Halloween night.
But it is that thing where it's just like the added anticipation, the added seasonal cheer always...
Makes the holiday more exciting I feel.
Down here the tradition is to have a family dinner and party on Christmas eve and then Christmas is just a chill day.
And you know what?
Whatever gives you a day off of work is a great day!
So hopefully you guys have some days off of work.
And you can relax this week.
And also next week?
Is it next week?
Yeah, next week is New Year!
And yeah!
I know some people have to work though.
If you have to work during this time...
Good luck!
Ganbare!
Fighto!
I don't have any plans though for New Year's.
I'll be in Japan.
Not sure what to do yet.
To be honest.
Hello Minto, hope you're having a good day today and ready to get gooder.
I'm ready to get greater!
Thank you!
I don't know what to do.
Maybe I'll find some...
Some type of shrine I can go haunt.
And do my first shrine visit.
Maybe.
I don't know.
Mogura gonna be popping on New Year's.
Oh yeah!
I'll be honest, I've never been.
Mogura is not very big.
It's very very tiny in there.
So it's also very difficult.
I think tickets already sold out.
But I mean, I can probably find a way in.
But I'm also just like...
I don't know if I wanna be packed with people.
New Year's Eve is my birthday!
Turning 32!
Kamen Dachi!
Wait, can I sing you happy birthday now?
Because I won't be around.
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Kamen Dachi!
Happy birthday!
And this is for all the birthdays that I will miss while I'm gone.
This is to all of you!
That I will miss singing your birthday while I'm away.
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday and happy new year!
Yes you!
You right there!
You!
Yeah!
Happy birthday everybody!
Happy birthday to Earth!
Whose birthday will be turning 2025.
Me?
Yeah you!
Earth?
Yeah, happy birthday to Earth on the new year!
Yeah, Earth didn't exist before the first year.
Duh.
That's not how old the Earth is.
It is according to the calendar.
The calendar says 2020.
You think the calendar is going to lie?
You think that they just skipped a billion years or anything?
That would be so silly!
What the...
Why would you do that?
Thanks for the happy birthday!
Mine is in precisely one week on the 30th.
We are already in Delta!
Happy birthday!
Your best bit yet.
It's already 2025?
Not yet!
Not yet.
Next week.
Koyu-chan!
What are you doing in Japan on the new year?
I'm free.
I have no plan.
Early Merry Christmas and mint bullet pies!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Merry early Christmas
I am going to play a game.
I don't know how long I'll go for today.
We'll see how I feel.
I'm a little bit tired just because I did some errands today.
Because I had to get ready for my trip.
I needed to pick some things up.
But overall I'm feeling good.
No way.
11-12?
No.
12... Has it...
Has it really... It has not been a month since I last played this game.
It must be December 11th, right?
Day, month.
OK.
I was going to say...
There is no way.
That confused me for a second.
I was like, what?
It was a European day.
OK.
I was going to be like...
There is no way.
Last time though the fight was so fun with the swords guys.
I loved that one.
We are on mission... We just cleared mission 5.
Maybe we'll get through a few missions.
I say maybe.
I mean I hope so.
I hope we'll get through a few missions today.
Taking it at my own minto pace.
So that...
Day, month, year always made more sense than month, day, year.
You're right.
I agree with you.
But my freedom brain has been taught otherwise.
So of course it's the first thing I think of.
America.
Anyway...
This
face.
What are these?
Demo Digest, Total Ranking, Bloody Palace, Co-op?
I can co-op.
There is multiplayer in this game?
Bloody Palace is too hard for you.
Don't doubt my limits.
It's like a 104 gauntlet.
I definitely don't want to do that.
I don't want to do it.
It's not that I can't.
I just don't want to.
That's all.
I could totally do it if I felt like it.
I just don't feel like it.
Duh!
Lady!
Wait, I think we saw this cutscene last time.
I watched it.
Right before I ended.
Oh, yeah, girl!
Look at her.
She's so sassy.
She looks... The heterochromia and the hairstyle look so much like Final Fantasy X-2, you know?
And the guns.
She's just Yuna.
She really is.
Why don't we have more heterochromia anymore?
When are you streaming X-2?
Streaming Final Fantasy games.
Do you want an actual game that will take a year?
And 6.
Mission 6, Family Ties.
Clear the trial and forge a new path.
What do we have here anyway?
I don't know how many robes I've got or anything.
The demo digest shows how scenes like this one were filmed using motion capture.
It's really fun to watch, but contains spoilers.
Thank you, Nicholas.
Thank you for telling me it contains spoilers.
Otherwise I would have been like, let's watch it.
We got Agni and Rudra.
Girls with Homophobia.
Stop it!
Final Fantasy VII Rebirth on PC.
Yes, we are getting it on PC.
Kaitlin.
I don't remember if I used this.
I have 7000 robes.
Nice.
Okay.
I'm just gonna go in and try to remember how to play.
The Goddess's Chamber.
I don't remember how to play.
Oh, this is gun.
This is attack.
Hold on.
Is it under status?
Status or...
Oh no, this area.
I feel like you guys say that about everywhere.
Control.
Let me just see.
Change the button setting.
No.
Wait, I want to...
Status file.
Thank you.
I knew it was under status.
I knew I was in the right place.
Oh, I knew it.
All the American traditions of tracking and calculating come from old colonial English.
But when they changed to newer formats, America was grandfathered in and became the odd one out.
Silly.
Too stubborn to change.
Okay, Devil Arms.
I just wanted a thing that would be like, points to A button.
A button does this.
Points to B button.
B button does this.
You know?
Let's see.
Is there nothing, anything like that?
It's not even telling me.
Oh, here we go.
L and A.
Okay.
Okay, it's just this kind of stuff.
And then you press A...
Oh, sorry.
No.
Not A.
You press... I was reading.
Press A.
You, um...
Press the...
The... Hold on.
I'm sorry.
I'm learning.
There we go.
Okay, okay.
And this is like... So A is whatever thing's special.
I remember.
Okay, they're a trick.
And then this is a normal attack.
This is a gun attack.
This is a jump.
This is to lock on.
Okay.
A is style.
What's this?
The goddess statue's piercing stare is focused on the front door.
Oh, that's a man!
I thought it was just a big old gloopy.
I thought it was just a bunch of gloop.
There's a guy there.
Wreckage is obstructing the path.
You can't go any further.
Says you.
Okay.
And then over there...
Is an invisible wall.
This room is kind of spooky.
Chamber of three trials.
What is this?
Passing?
What is man but a big old gloop?
It's true!
Passing one trial still shows lacking.
Passing two trials expands horizons.
Passing all trials unlocks one's true potential.
What's this one?
Your wisdom will be put to the test in the chamber ahead.
Use your lifetime experience.
From the crawling infant...
I have to remember when I was a baby?
Oh god.
From the crawling infant to the man standing tall and finally to the old man leaning on his cane.
Okay, so I have to use my smarts here.
Your technique will be put to the test in the chamber ahead.
Overcome the onslaught of obstacles to guarantee your future.
Green.
Green women.
Your warrior's heart will be put to the test in the chamber ahead.
Light all the crests to suppress the evil spirit's rage.
That's me!
Okay, let's go do the smarts first.
Trial of wisdom.
From when I'm a baby.
Oh gosh.
I'm gonna have to remember how to freaking play this game.
Why are there so many guys?
Oh wait, wait, wait.
These are the guys that split, is it not?
Oh no!
Wait!
Don't these guys split?
Oh no, no.
Oh no.
I don't remember what to do.
Wait, how do I...
Thank you.
Ouch!
Oh, I'm gonna die.
I remembered at the... Well, I didn't remember.
You guys helped me.
Thanks.
Oh wait.
This has two.
This has three.
This has four.
Three?
Because of the three try?
Oh wait, because baby, man, old man.
I was wrong.
Was I not thinking?
I thought I was... I thought I was...
I truly thought I...
Oh god.
Destroy, destroy, destroy.
Okay, now I can become a sword master.
There we go.
Okay.
I did it.
I can leave?
Like you think?
Or are these doors... Are these doors working now?
Gotta restart?
Okay, okay.
I have to restart the trial?
No way.
Well, if it's not two and it's not three, it's gotta be four.
Two, three, four.
Four is your lucky number.
So true!
Spooky.
Why four?
I'm trying to think though.
Why was it four?
Babies crawl at four?
I don't know anything about babies.
Wait, what?
No, they should be walking by then.
Actually a cracked ass gamer.
Are you calling me an ass crack?
Bruce Wayne, I'm gonna expose you.
Everybody, Bruce Wayne is Batman!
Okay.
They should be walking by four.
Is it because they use their arms and their legs?
And so they have four... like they are a dog.
And then a man... that's why they brought up the cane.
So a man would be standing on his own two legs and then a caned man would have three legs.
And then...
I'll never...
I have the essence of intelligence.
I'll never ever...
Impalpable knowledge of the ancient ones.
After this... oh sorry.
Offer this to the goddess to open a new path.
So I can just leave?
You just killed my whole family, Mint.
I can't believe you've done this to a cracked ass gamer.
Sorry.
What do I... it doesn't like... I can just go back in if I felt like it?
But I took the...
I do not want to go back in.
No!
This one is the... oh gosh.
Wait, what's technique?
Oh, yes.
Trial of skill.
You guys, if I fail this you can truly say skill issue.
You know?
You can say skill issue.
Gun, trick, sword.
I think I will want to be a trickster for this.
How do you dodge this one?
How do you dodge that?
The one that comes up from above.
Oh, you can walk under it?
Oh, for real?
I made it.
Essence of technique.
Masterful techniques of the ancient ones.
Offer this to the goddess to open a new path.
No way.
Oh my god, are you kidding me?
Why?
You couldn't just let me be?
Run over, sword, sword.
Oh, I'm such an idiot.
Oh, ouch.
Take it, take it, take it, take it, take it, take it.
Crazy.
Oh, there is more.
Take it, take it, take it, take it.
He's already dead, but I won't let him die.
I won't let him die.
He's already dead, but he's mine forever.
Ten thousand stab wounds.
Yeah, we did that.
OK, and then this one was...
Our heart will be put to the test.
Light all of the crests to suppress the evil spirit's rage.
Good job, welcome to my bishop.
Thank you.
You don't have to do the third trial?
Oh no, wait, really?
Wait, this one is optional.
It's the hardest one.
You should.
There is a reward.
There is a weapon if you do.
How difficult are we saying?
This is the hardest one.
The reward sucks.
There is a neat reward.
It's not worth trying to find out.
Let's try it.
We can try it.
What am I lighting up?
I hate the inverse camera.
Oh, this thing.
What's wrong with them?
Oh god, they're scaring me.
Can I kill these guys or no?
What if I just...
And right
away...
And I hit, hit, hit...
There
is more?
Oh god, I tried to move.
Oh gosh.
I don't remember how to dodge stuff, to be honest.
Oh no, wait...
Which one?
Oh my god.
The music is kind of awesome though.
Wait, oh no, the next one.
Oh my god.
Wait, he's purple.
Is there another one?
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
He's tricky.
He's a tough guy.
You wanna be a tough guy, get it?
Nice.
Two birds with one stone, baby.
Oh my god, again?
Kill, kill, kill, kill!
Nice.
Oh my god, I'm gonna die.
I'm gonna...
Oh man.
Right when...
Right when I got the grorb.
Right in front of the health, so sad.
Million stab is too slow, but good first try.
I'll be honest, I just hit the X button a whole lot.
I just hit the buttons...
How much money do I got?
Is there something that I was trying to get?
I can't remember.
Maybe I was saving up for a thing or two.
Air hike on...
What even is the jet stream?
R, L while holding X.
R while holding X.
Oh, I'm not even using it.
I don't even have them equipped.
I'm stupid.
I'm dumb.
It's like Stinger.
How do you switch?
Wait.
I don't remember.
I remember, I remember.
I'm walking.
I remembered.
Essence of technique.
Nothing happened.
Essence of intelligence.
The battle theme is called Taste the Blood.
The lyrics have two meanings.
It either means the enemy is weak or the player is stinky.
It's almost like a roast song.
That's so funny.
I don't know.
I'm just gonna keep going guys.
Is this one of those guys that I have to do like a...
Do the combo to?
Oh yeah, he's losing it.
He's losing it.
Oh, no.
Hold on, let me...
Gales and flame.
I lost it!
I'm like trying to jump, but it's like because of the camera angle it's making me dodge.
I'm not good at it.
That would have been awesome if I had...
I did it.
Blue orb fragment.
He was trying to tell me.
I just kept beating him up.
Lady!
Oh no!
Papa?
Why do you say it like that?
Only I say it like that.
Papa?
Oh no!
They have the same...
What a jerk!
Oh my god, lady!
The book.
Throwing the book at her face is insane.
Yay, mission clear!
We got an A on orbs though.
Don't worry about it.
Dads.
And we just met the dad.
It was all according to plan.
Dads.
Minto got the dump truck.
Every wisp knows this tbh.
What do you mean by that?
What prompted you to say this?
What prompted you to say that?
It's okay if I messed up.
Don't worry about it.
Behold Dante's wrist.
Well, this is my kind of rain.
No wonder the sky looks so funny today.
Let me go!
Let you go?
It's rain and women.
But it would be a waste if you ended up as just a pretty stain.
Oh my god!
Last of all, happy birthday!
Here I am trying to help you.
And you show your thanks by shooting me?
Twice!
No Dante, fight harder.
She is so hot.
So he is a demon too.
I'm beginning to think I've got rotten luck with women.
Oh I missed the 7!
I didn't see it.
I didn't see it guys, dang it.
Where was it?
The blood stain.
I'm tired of holding back.
Master Walt!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday Master Walt!
Happy birthday!
OK.
A chance meeting.
Duel of the demon children.
Let's go.
We are in a dark corridor.
That's where it was.
The 7.
Heaven rise chamber.
That's a lot of roars.
Just saying.
The mat worst she can say is no.
Or literally shoots me in the head.
Yes, but...
OK.
Hold on.
We'll come back here.
Where did you see a blorb?
Nice.
There is a lot in here.
Oh my goodness.
Please!
Remember you can move the camera.
Not here.
Don't forget your wall run.
Oh!
Thank you.
Wait.
Wall jump or wall run?
Style button.
I don't go up high enough though.
I don't go high enough.
I feel maybe...
Oh my goodness.
I don't think we'll ever get it.
It's a sad sad roar world up there.
I'm gonna try... Let me get all the stuff that's in here.
Because apparently there is a blorb somewhere.
I do not see it though.
Boing.
Where is a blorb?
If there is a blorb I'll have it.
I don't see it though.
Blorbless.
Oh yeah.
So many rorbs.
We are just going higher and higher and higher.
Wait, what if I fall all the way down?
Down is the correct way?
Wait, actually...
I was just trying to collect stuff.
Someone said there was a shiny on the floor.
I think I missed it.
It's at the very top.
Thank goodness there is no fall damage.
I think we'd be in trouble.
I think we would have a bad time.
I think.
Probably.
Green door!
Pitch black void?
I can clearly see.
What are you talking about?
Who named this place?
I think they need to get their eyes checked.
Oh boy.
More rorbs!
What is this?
Looks like a fancy...
Something I want.
Oh gosh, I'm so lost.
What's the mission?
It's a light?
But it's like helped by him.
So they go into defense and then they go into attack.
Shiny.
Wait, how do I get this?
Grab the shiny Dante.
What is this?
Stone pillar embroidered with skulls.
Similar pillar lies to the right.
Something appears to be missing from it.
Why couldn't I pick it up?
Hello?
Just a vital start.
OK.
Get me out of here please.
Bye!
Your love keeps lifting me higher and higher.
Is that the lyrics?
Am I going to fight a hot lady?
Is she going to come to life?
Oh, come on!
Why are there two of them?
Oh
my god, are they just making tons of guys?
Ouchie!
There
are so many guys.
Easy mode is now selectable.
I already got that achievement.
Sirens.
I definitely read Shrek.
The sorrowful shriek of the siren calms even the most ferocious of flames.
I definitely read...
Definitely read Shrek.
Hey yo, what do you mean all these little caskets are...
Well, that singular casket was hiding a robe.
All dead people holding out on me, huh?
Alrighty!
OK, these don't break.
What's in here?
Lift room.
Yo bro, do you even lift?
What?
I don't know if I can get this you guys.
I don't think I've ever gotten a triple.
Oh no, I lost it!
I was so close.
What's that noise?
What?
Oh, it's the flames.
It's the flames coming back.
That scared me.
Sword master midair... Wait, what does that mean?
You have combos.
Wait.
Guys, I don't know...
Using the same attack is worthless.
Yes...
Yes, I...
I know.
I'm sure she didn't know that.
I hope you're being sarcastic.
But does she know?
I don't know.
Wait,
if I do this...
This...this...
This...this...this...
Wait, this...this...this...
This...this...
This...this...this...
Just don't use the same attack in a row VTuber!
Just don't do the same attack in a row and it works.
D'oh!
Just do the same attack.
Just do consistency.
Same attack three times.
And when I jump though...
Ok, let's see.
Maybe I can add something into the rotation.
I don't know if you know, but you need to add variety of moves.
Not the same ones in a row.
PSYCHOS!
Guys, why couldn't you tell me what PSYCHOS just told me?
I didn't know that.
Guys!
That would have helped me so much.
No help.
My bad.
Ah, sheesh.
Plenty of attacks to try, but ok.
Oh my gosh, Seiren.
No need to get sassy with me, ok?
Ok?
No need to get sassy with me.
So maybe if I...
I was doing a three hit combo, so basically I was doing...
Stinger...up...spin.
Stinger...oh, but see I'm pressing forward and it does it just as a normal attack.
Why?
Why does it not do a stinger?
Maybe try...wait, I can't get on this side.
Do normal attacks too?
Oh, ok.
Normal attacks help?
Ok.
Oh
shoot.
My finger slipped.
No!
I had the good pattern!
Hey!
I
don't know why sometimes he jumps up in the air.
I'm not pressing jump.
I give up.
That's ok.
What was it anyway?
What do you get?
A dead end?
Try this.
Oh god.
Oh, a blower piece?
That's it?
You just get a blower piece?
Elevator control panel.
There is not enough power to operate it.
I see.
Seems to be an elevator that goes down, but it's not working.
And we know why.
The tranquil soul's room.
And let's put in this little face.
Stone pillar?
Wait, what?
The thing that I got.
What was that?
Wait, what did I receive from the other room?
Use it at the main entrance.
Where are those guys?
Oh, they all left.
This is a complete aside to your smoking sexy styling, but your combo noises really make me want to see you play the DMC reboot.
Dino Dante's in name only loves to grunt during his combos.
Grunt.
There were other doors.
There were a lot of other doors.
I think I jumped a little further down than I wanted to.
Is it to this?
The divine library.
This is not...
Oh, it is a combat.
But also...oh no.
No, I don't want...
Wait.
Oh shoot.
I didn't learn how to defeat these guys.
You'll get it.
You'll aim, Dante.
Dante.
Just a little bit down.
There you go, buddy.
You can't see?
He's coming for me?
Helps if you aim at the enemy.
It's not me.
It's Dante.
It ain't me.
It's all Dante, baby.
I'm keeping my distance because these guys kind of scare me.
I don't know why.
They kind of freak me out.
Why did you come after me?
I didn't come to you.
I can't use these hecking camera angles.
Ah!
Sorry for the loud gun.
Oh my god, it's so loud.
I don't like them.
I just hop really slowly, but there is something about them.
I got...
That's not a robe.
A piece of...
Which grants amazing power.
They say it was once used as an energy source.
Anything in here?
This grand library.
I could have just chilled up here.
And attack them.
Wait, how is that a puzzle?
Puzzle.
How is that...
The blue door is supposed to be you solve something, is it not?
And then the red doors are you kill all the enemies.
Puzzle.
You
killed the correct amount.
I see.
Alright, hold on.
Wait, Dante!
Wait Dante!
Hold on, there were other doors, were there not?
No.
Only has three doors.
Oh, and we went in this one.
So, back to the elevator.
The big energy source.
Oh no!
Where is my son?
Welcome to bamboo ship.
I hope you find him.
Hold on.
Oh, here we go.
To the lying room.
The not pitch black void.
Oh shoot, they are back.
Oh, things look like I could...
Sorry, my Castlevania brain turned on for a second there.
My Castlebrania brain was just like...
My Castlebrania, if you will.
Was definitely like, yeah, you got this.
You can just destroy those.
Castlebrania.
We use the fragment.
And now the elevator works.
And it said it goes down?
We went all the way up just to go back down?
I remember, this leads to the entrance.
I thought, or rather, I remember...
Are we at the entrance?
Yeah.
I also have 13,000.
We could get stinger level 2.
You can enter the fire door.
I forgot about that, thank you guys.
Stinger level 2 increases the range.
I'm like, do we get that or do we get air hike?
I don't think, I feel like I'm not going to use Agni and Rudra very much.
TMC 3 was originally supposed to be Silent Hill 64.
But then Nintendo sent them TMCA.
This guy?
Oh, there we go.
Crimson flames twist and dance around the door, keeping all would-be trespassers at bay.
Oh, I have the...
Guys, I'm...OK.
I knew that would happen.
Oh my god, the light.
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh gosh, I keep...
Everything's fine.
I got a gorb!
Yippee!
OK.
Back in TMC 1 I would have been thanking the heavens.
I don't know what's wrong with you either.
I don't know.
Cursed Skull Chamber.
Who's naming these places?
And over here we have the bathroom on your right.
And to your left we have the cursed skull chamber.
I broke them though.
Probably the bald dude.
Dad?
Yeah, probably he was just like...
This is the cursed...
He would say it in a weird way, you know.
This is the cursed skull room.
What is this?
What am I trying to bash in?
Hold on.
I can't see with this camera.
Uh...
Am I...
Do I hit it to swing it to break something?
Oh, I just break it?
Yeah,
is the room cursed or the skulls cursed?
That's such a great question.
That is a great question.
Oh...
What?
No, nothing.
Where did it go?
Oh, I have to do it again.
Is it a cursed chamber for skulls or a chamber for cursed skulls?
Oh wait, this is...
Did it fix itself?
Oh my god.
I don't like the camera angle in this.
The camera angle makes it so tricky!
Dante, move please!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, lock on does nothing either.
What if I did this instead?
OK.
Nope, it's not doing anything.
No damage!
Oh my god, where did it go?
Jump on it, Mint.
Yeah, I learned that.
You can't jump on it.
I'm trying.
I'm trying, God.
Oh my god.
Stop!
Dante!
Get up on the Hydra's back!
Get up on the Wrecking Ball's back!
Oh my god, Buster, you and I have the same brain.
Might be a good job for...yeah, you know what?
Let's try that.
It just runs away so fast!
I got a crystal!
Indiana Jones.
An eerie sculpture made of magic crystal.
It seems to be a piece of a larger creation.
I think I know.
I knew this was going to happen.
No!
You bastard!
You!
Die!
You die!
You die right now!
I don't want to deal with your shit!
You stinking man!
Ouch!
Die!
Yeah!
OK, now we can deal with everything else.
Oh my god, I'm gonna die!
I do have a Grorb.
Or the Vitality Star.
I'm
gonna die!
I mean, I guess?
I mean, I guess.
Oh, they hit hard!
Die!
Oh, ouchie ouchie.
I'm trying to stinger spam for real.
But they're all... I can't see.
I can't see.
I can't see!
Oh, please!
Go away!
I can't see!
Oh my god, stop, please.
I think Cerberus is good for groups.
I'll remember that next time.
Oh, there's...
Editor, no, she will not remember that.
That's not true!
I live...well, I don't live, but I do learn!
I do learn!
It's not true, I remember things.
Sometimes I don't remember them immediately, but I remember.
And now I'm getting Grorbs.
Now will I remember it next time I play?
That's debatable.
I want that one.
Oh, there's more right there.
How do I go downstairs?
Let's see.
Over here.
You stinking guy!
Elevator at the bottom.
Yeah, I'm getting the Grorbs first, you guys.
I just said that.
Oh, there it is.
I'm getting the Grorbs first.
That's probably enough.
My bad, get that bag, G.
I got it.
Alrighty, now let's go take our crystal skull.
No!
No, I'm not feeling very tranquil!
I'm not feeling very tranquil!
Alright, let's try it then.
Oh my god, I don't have the double...I don't have air height.
Sorry, I'm turning it down.
It's so loud.
Wait, where do I...
Do I have the crystal skull still?
How do I see if I have it?
Oh, ok.
Easy peasy.
Good, good, good.
Let's see.
Ok, no worries.
My Grorbs!
Grorbs!
We are all good to go.
You know what?
I'll try using Cerberus from the start though.
He's like, get the hell away from me, you stupid ass!
I wish you'd just die already!
Jump and grab my riches.
I like Cerberus a lot actually.
Ok, more!
More!
No!
This guy!
God!
Parry!
Parry the platypus!
Ok,
I'm switching back.
Ok.
Oh shit.
I was so close to timing it.
Get
him!
Oh, he just disappeared!
Oh, that's what I meant to do.
God, you bastard!
It's like we are back at chapter 1.
No, I don't want to use Royal Guard.
I'm not good at it.
We were able to take care of these guys pretty quickly with this, so...
Stop it!
Where's the others?
Already.
Why can't I see his health?
It's so annoying.
Oh my god.
That was so good!
Oh no, that was not good though.
You bastard!
Jump!
Oh shit.
What?
The health for the enemy is the green part of the lock on circle.
I see, I see, I see.
We got some decent...well, I got some dodges in there.
Use the crystal skull!
Hello, R.O.R.B.
R.O.R.B.
Machine And...
This thing doesn't give you better stuff for...
For combos or anything, right?
He's just a...
He just gives you stuff.
Time to get motivated.
You guys are scaring me.
Actually this whole scene is scary.
You guys are scaring me!
OK.
No spoilers, no spoilers.
I won't look in chat anymore.
I won't look in chat.
I don't think I have enough money for anything.
When will my sword master level up?
Truly.
Should I buy items?
I don't know.
You'll either be scared or hot and bothered.
What about...what about all three?
Hold on, I'm going to put some eye drops in.
My ectoplasm is starting to dry out.
This weather...
Makes my ectoplasm all dried up.
Stay hydrated everybody.
Stay hydrated.
15k for a blorb.
I know it's a scam, isn't it?
So rude.
OK.
Eye hydration.
Hydration.
Hold on, my eyes are all blurry now.
I guess I...I mean, I'll see what I get into and then see if I want to buy anything.
I'm scared.
You guys are scaring me.
I want to see what happens first.
And then I'll see if I want to buy any vital stars.
Don't attack me door.
Oh my god, it's raining.
How is it raining right here?
Are we not under...
Oh, is that just a light?
Oh, it's just a light.
OK.
I'm coming for you, brother.
I always wanted a brother.
Why does this feel like a final boss?
Are we going to have the scene from the opening?
No food.
No drinks.
And the only babe just left.
I can't hear you.
Over the music.
I was so eager to see you, I couldn't concentrate on preparations for the bash.
What?
At any rate, it's been a whole year since we last met.
How about a kiss from your little brother?
Or better yet, how about a kiss from this?
Did he just wink?
It's like that coffee commercial.
Peak of darkness.
OK, I can do that too.
Oh, my health is not the same as yours.
Uh...
Got it.
I don't think I was motivated enough.
Hello?
Where is your motivation?
Oh, gosh, you guys.
OK.
I almost want to watch a tutorial on this video.
Or like a how-to.
You know, sometimes before I fight bosses, I like to watch people fight them.
I had it last night after...
After Astro Bot.
I played Astro Bot yesterday.
And I unlocked the secret last level.
And I watched someone how to do it.
And then I saw one of the comments and they were just like, after I watched this, I did it in one try.
It was so good.
How to get motivated.
Oh, my god.
Trickster could be good here.
I'm scared of him.
Basic strategy is to dodge and then counterattack.
Watching how other players helps with learning and getting good.
Skip your cutscene, sorry.
He's gonna say, where is your motivation?
And then he's gonna attack me.
I'm gonna be scared.
Where is your motivation?
I tried to leave.
Oh, my god.
Where is your motivation?
Motivation...
Maybe if I can slowly...
Oh, my god.
He still got me.
Maybe I can...
Maybe I can slowly but surely chip him down.
Where is your motivation?
That's not good.
Oh, my god.
Now I'm motivated.
Me too.
Where is your motivation?
Oh, shit.
Ah,
no!
That was too slow.
Where is your motivation?
Come here.
This may be fun.
Oh, shit.
I meant to dodge.
I'm so stupid.
Oh, gosh.
I got greedy.
Did you just call me scum?
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Where is your motivation?
I'm gonna... Oh, 1 HP and a dream.
Scum.
Oh, I don't know why I did that.
I don't know why I did that.
I don't know why I went back in.
It's okay though.
I don't think I would have made it.
Good second try.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Oh, wait.
I think I might buy...
I might buy a small, small vital store.
Where is your motivation?
You got plenty of stuff to use, Mito.
Mate is always flexible.
You got this.
Thank you!
I don't know.
I think I'm...
I'm like an old dog when it comes to...
I just like to have one thing that I like to use.
And I don't want to switch it up.
I know that's probably like... I mean, that's so rigid.
And it makes me not as good of a gamer.
But I just... That's just... That's how I like to do it.
I don't know.
I think it's great when a game gives you lots of options.
So it's just like, oh, if you don't like playing with this...
You can play with this instead.
And if you're able to be a type of person that's just like...
Okay, now I hit and then I switch to this weapon...
And I hit and then I switch to this weapon and I hit...
Like, good for you.
But I just... I don't have the...
Dexterity.
I don't have the dexterity to do it.
Happy Christmas week!
Thanks, Jacob!
Fun fact, Dan Southworth, Virgil's VA, had a cold during recording of this game.
That's why he sounds so nasally and nerdy.
Really?
Oh, he didn't?
Wait.
It's a lie?
Oh, it's a myth.
Oh, he debunked this.
Aww.
You were trying.
Reach, you thought you had a fun fact, but instead it was a lie.
It was not a fact at all.
It was a lie fact.
Maybe.
Sorry, I heard about it.
No, don't apologize.
See, you guys made him feel bad.
You guys made him feel bad.
I'm confused though.
I was on Trickster.
How do I have double jump?
I thought only Sword Master had that.
How do I have air hike?
Oh, it's the weapon.
That's right.
It's not the style, it's the weapon.
Thank you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's right.
Don't worry, with this one I died like a hundred times to this guy and he was doing really well.
I do hope he finds that motivation though.
Yeah, the weapon has the double jump.
You were doing great on that second attempt.
I'm just afraid for phase two.
I'm afraid for phase two.
Oh.
Are you gonna move?
Where's your motivation?
Oh, why did I do that?
Okay, I need to be able to see there.
I can't see anything with the camera.
The camera does not let you... The camera is automatically changing, by the way, in case you're wondering.
Why do you put your sword away?
Oh.
Now I'm motivated.
Why are you standing there then?
You're scaring me, Virgil.
Virgil, you're scaring me!
Oh shit.
Counter, counter.
I'm concentrated.
I'm concentrating.
Sorry if I don't talk much.
Where's your motivation?
Skum.
Now I'm motivated.
Yeah.
Why are you just standing there then?
Where's your motivation?
I love the way he says this.
It's so funny.
I'm glad I got stinger too.
Oh shit.
Skum.
Oh shit, shit, shit, shit.
Leave.
Oh, his hair!
His hair fell down.
Oh shit.
Oh my god, he's everywhere.
What is that?
Oh no, round two.
Haha, phase two.
Your hair, Virgil.
Now I'm motivated.
Die.
Where did he go?
Ok.
Learned, learned, learned.
Ok, come here.
Skum, skum here.
That one's spooky.
Skum here, baby.
Sorry.
You're scaring me, Virgil.
Virgil, you're scaring me when you stand over there.
In the dark.
Did you name the void of pitch black darkness?
Because we need to talk about that, buddy.
We need to talk about that.
Can you come out here?
Taunt back.
Can I?
I don't remember how to taunt.
Oops.
That was close.
Select.
Oh god, my finger can't reach over there.
I did it.
We're circling.
This is like a real battle.
No!
Nice, nice, nice.
Where's your motivation?
Come on, man.
Come on.
It's the way he just stands there.
Now
I'm motivated.
Ok, no...
No...
I'm getting sweaty hands.
Where's your motivation?
Come on, wimp.
Oh, that's what he's saying.
Wimp.
Come on, wimp.
Oh, shoot.
Why did I do that?
This may be fun.
Oh, sh... damn.
Just a little bit.
No!
Scum.
Sibling rivalry.
Do it.
Yippee!
What?
Oh my god, that's insane.
I think I've seen someone beating him so cleanly with no experience and on first playthrough you game.
Thank you, Gaito!
And it was second try too.
That was second try, right?
Or did I die one more time?
I don't remember.
He asked where my motivation was.
Third try.
Still, third time's the charm, right?
Damn it.
This is... this is the opening.
What about motivation?
Thank you for the Hakushupla.
He got our necklace.
No,
our necklace!
Mommy's necklace!
Oh my god, so brutal.
Dante, get up!
You got shot in the head earlier.
Are you ok?
Dante!
I can't do it.
Jack is back, baby.
Thank you for the raid.
Hi, Julius.
Dante!
Was that my devil trigger?
It was?
No way.
Yippee!
Boi.
Doi.
Boi!
Let's go!
Oh, jeez.
Minky Gaming!
Great job, you were really motivated.
Thank you!
Grimble Grumble.
Oh, your profile picture scares me.
Thank you for the...
Thank you for the 6th one.
Fun fact, the devil trigger forms in this game were designed by Kaneko of FSMT fame.
Oh, cool!
Did I save?
Yes.
Ok.
Are you ready for peak style, Minto?
I don't know.
What was that?
Two missions in two hours?
Let
me turn it up.
Dante!
What is this?
Take him down Dante!
Take him down!
The eagles!
Woohoo!
Oh my god!
Do
that Dante, they'll spawn more!
Maybe he wants that though.
Oh my god!
Holy shit.
What the hell is... A whale?
Huh?
Burst forth from the great demon's womb.
No way!
We went through all of that just to get bored?
I don't think I got any robes, did I?
Oh, I have 15,000.
I really do like servers.
I do a lot.
Help pack.
Spin the nunchucks around in a propeller-like motion.
You can buy porbs.
I can.
Oh, you're right!
I can buy the plorbs.
Porbs.
Tinyzoo!
Thanks for the time gift!
Thank you, thank you.
That is the best DMC cutscene IMO.
Porb time!
First act slash third of the game done.
Current thoughts, Minto?
That's my thoughts.
Something about this game in particular is most of the times Dante does some awesome show-offy shit...
...he almost immediately gets dunked on afterwards to show his inexperience.
You silly guy.
Okay, maybe I should save for the porb zone.
Oh, I see it.
Well, I mean, I have money.
You know what?
I'm gonna buy a porb.
Porb!
Porb time!
Yeah.
Oh, is this a swimming level?
Please say no.
Oh, oh
gosh.
Devil trigger!
Yeah!
Oh no.
It's like this effect.
The seal has been dispelled, opening up a single stone tusk.
Four more tusks remain.
Okay.
Any up here?
No.
Oh, I hate this effect.
Does this hurt me?
Yes, it does.
Oh, I hate this effect so much.
Why do they always do this?
Oh, this is... okay.
Is this a school, guys?
No, the children!
What is this over here?
Devil's teeter-totter.
Ride the elevator to the top?
Oh no, not this stuff again.
It's this one!
I hate this.
I think we did this one before and I gave up.
I'm pretty sure.
Because you fall off so easily.
What's the cheese for it?
What's the cheese?
Gouda?
Oh, don't do that.
Wait, why is it going down?
Wait, why did it go down?
Why did it go down?
Too much weight?
Are you kidding me right now?
Oh, I didn't mean to style on the wall.
I meant to leave.
You're still alive?
Is it because he's blocking?
Oh my god, there we go.
Hairy god.
For real though.
Holy hell.
Get me out of here please.
Isn't this the skull that releases you from the torture?
Please let me leave.
Please.
I don't want to be here anymore.
I don't want to style on the wall.
Try to walk out the door.
What door?
There's a door?
Anyway, nobody cared.
Ouch.
A seal has been released opening up a single stone tusk.
Three more tusks remain.
Okay, I found one.
By the pirate ship.
Awesome.
Two more tusks remain.
Is there any on the pirate ship?
There's a lore fragment on it.
Remember hell from DMC1?
Yes, I do very...
I think though, it's not really bothering me so much today.
The effect.
I think maybe I was just not feeling well that day.
Because right now, like it's annoying, but I'm not feeling like I'm going to throw up or anything.
So, that's a win I suppose.
I was trying to get up to the...
Does it still suck?
Yeah.
I think maybe also it could have been the graphics from the other game.
Potentially.
Because I don't get motion sick in games very much.
So I feel like it was a me issue.
What was the other thing that I was trying to get to?
Come
on.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, I didn't even notice this.
Ouch!
Guys, this is looking pretty sussy.
One more tusk remains.
Nice.
This is where I was trying to get up to.
There's so much up here.
I guess we are technically going into the womb, huh?
Get me!
Yeah!
I don't know if I want to go in there.
I want this though.
Dang it!
I got... I missed one.
Leviathan's intestines.
Intestines.
This way, right?
Oh, I got burnt.
I was like, who's trying to fight me?
Who wants a piece of this?
Oh, it's so gross.
It's so nasty.
Give us a break from...
from that...
I'm just going to buy another... another porb.
We are in the heart core.
An organ writhes ferociously on the other side of the membranous wall.
You can't get any closer now.
Alright, we go through.
This is so gross!
It's just a membrane, just slice and dice it.
We're back in the intestines.
I can't see anything?
I don't want to fall into acid.
Oh my god.
I'm running.
I'm dying.
I was trying to save the DT, but...
Understandable.
Oh my god, he's so fast!
He's already caught up to me!
How
do I get past him?
Oh, I made it past.
Dummy.
Anyway...
Hi!
Why are there things in here?
He's got parasites!
Oh my god.
He's got... Oh, these are nasty!
Oh, there's another guy over there.
Oh.
Hold on, let me get my riches, please.
Please.
Stinger spam!
Anyway...
Where are we?
This is so gross.
Why is it so foggy in here?
This is just...
I don't like body heat.
We're in the rectum?
Is that the...
Is that the real bi-hole?
Oh my god.
Or dodge?
Something.
Nope.
This.
That's what I need you to do.
There's so many guys.
Oh, I forgot I was a trickster.
I've never seen a... Is this like a prolapsed anus?
Does that count?
Maybe I try this.
Oh my god, they don't stop coming.
They don't stop coming, huh?
Until they stop coming.
Where's my riches?
I don't think we should touch that.
We got the ignis fatis!
It's not outward, Vinto.
Oh, you're right.
We're on the inside.
The souls of those sent to hell for the sin of jealousy.
They're Leviathan's energy source.
Why is it so dark all of a sudden?
He's got no energy, so... Oh god.
Isn't this where we just got chased?
And I thought it smelled bad on the outside.
What are you smelling?
This looks like a chicken.
I wonder... I wonder...
What did they use to create this texture?
You know?
But it smells like even a wood in there.
Yeah.
Like McDonald's.
Meat?
You think like just meat?
I don't know.
It looks...
Colonoscopy video.
That's what I'm thinking.
Oh god.
What is this?
Oh my god.
This...
Again?
It's so unfair!
Okay, I made it.
Oh my god.
Those guys are downstairs.
They're trying to get to me.
Yeah, little babies.
Yeah, I can't reach.
This is a message to you from the future.
Future messages to follow.
You must remember that whatever you do in the game, don't under any circumstances...
Don't what?
Oh god.
I'm afraid to fall down.
No,
that's not who I was...
Nevermind.
I didn't realize they were dead.
Oh my god.
There was another hole.
Oh wait.
No, we're going back to the main hole.
This hole.
Was this the hole?
Oh dang.
I thought he was down for a second.
God, guns really do suck in this game, huh?
They're just little monkeys.
Two little monkeys jumping on the bed.
One gets shot right in the head.
Mama went to the doctor and the doctor said...
No more monkeys jumping on the bed.
Oh god.
Watch your step.
Watch your step now.
Wait, did I go the wrong way?
Oh, I think I turned around.
Is the camera angle changed?
Okay, there we go.
Oh god.
How did this grow back so fast?
Time for the worst boss in the game.
Oops,
my bad.
Membrane.
Use the Ignis Fatus.
Oh
god, he absorbs these.
I saw him do it earlier.
Or we saw it do it earlier.
That's right.
Oh my god.
No.
What is this?
What are you doing?
What are those?
Oh, okay.
I thought I...
I definitely don't feel confident.
What the hell are you doing?
And swing.
Swing, swing.
Oh, okay.
You can't swing though.
This boss sucks.
All my DT and all my stuff.
You guys are just collateral damage to my jumps.
You guys are just collateral damage.
I'm sorry.
Okay, nice.
One down.
No!
My DT!
Are you kidding me?
What?
I
can only get him.
Wait.
Stop!
DT!
Ew.
I gotta get him when his thing is hanging out.
Reminds me of Butaro when he's licking his pink thing.
That's what he does.
I guess he cleans it.
I don't know.
Damn.
Where did all this DT come from for you to absorb, huh?
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
I lost so much health there.
I'm not gonna make it, you guys!
Shit me.
Shit.
Stop taking my DT, please.
Now he does the lasers!
Which I don't know if I like more or not.
Oh my god.
And he recovers health even?
Did he recover health?
I think he did.
Oh shit.
I hate this.
I don't want this anymore.
And he eats my...
He eats my grorbs.
Which I don't get any grorbs.
He defeats those guys and he gets grorbs, but I defeat those guys and I get no grorbs!
What is this favoritism?
I wasted my... I wasted my... Wait, I don't have it anymore, right?
Nope.
My vital star.
So yeah, the guy on the left...
I think we have to just stick with the guy on the left.
Because we can't have him...
We can't have him healing.
I think.
I think...
I think it's okay.
Because...
Let me see if I can purchase anything.
Oh whoops.
I can't buy... I could buy another plorb.
Plorb.
My biggest concern... I don't mind if he eats the grorbs and does the lasers.
My biggest concern is him healing.
But I guess if we just do more damage with the DT...
Then he could...
If we do more damage with the DT then he can heal.
It might be okay.
He's gotta stick his thing out more.
He's gotta stick his thing out more so I can hit it.
Let's try it with... Okay, hold on.
Alright.
And then...
I'm going to focus on the right guy.
This guy over here.
We're gonna focus on him.
Make this fast.
I wish I landed any of those shots.
So funny.
And to make it all worse, you gotta have so many of these guys.
Wait, is he still alive?
There we go.
His thing!
You guys!
We leveled up our style!
Hold down R, then press A while holding forward.
Oh, dang it.
Oh my goodness.
He didn't do the laser beam.
Oh, he's still absorbing.
Oh, there it is.
Ouch!
I tried to jump!
Oh shoot.
Oh god.
Screw it.
Maybe that was a mistake, but I needed the health.
I mistimed it.
There's like a little break in between.
Oh, that's why I don't like the...
That's why I don't like the lasers because they are stronger than...
Well, I never get hit by the orbs because they are so slow.
I don't know.
Does this style upgrade carry over?
Ok, so it was forward A?
Is that it?
That's it?
I'm confused.
It just throws your sword.
Check
the style.
Files.
Sword Master.
Sword Pierce.
Curl your sword at the enemy, skewering them with it.
R, L, A.
Oh, but that's not what I meant.
Ok, but...
How does that...
Will that interfere with...
Scroll down.
The flicker.
Oh, let's see.
What, the million carats?
Repeatedly press A while executing the crystal.
Slam your nunchucks into the ground to create a huge glacier.
And then crawler.
Attack far away enemies by plunging your swords into the ground to roll out a large carpet of flame in their direction.
Ok, I might be a little too slow for this.
But maybe this would be good.
Hold on, let's try it.
Wait, sorry, what was it?
What did I need to do?
Was it R?
Ah,
I got it, I got it.
Nope.
There we go.
Two on this.
I wonder if it's too slow though.
Smash it?
Ok.
Let's try it.
That's so mean.
What if I was just like, oh no, wait, I'm gonna buy a thing.
They wouldn't let me.
They don't want me to spend my money.
Ok, fine game.
Two on this.
It's cool.
On
this.
It's cool.
Holy shit.
I just noticed it was...
No, the pink thing!
I mean the green thing.
Two on this.
You know what, it's fine.
Wow, it's so good.
It's cool.
Two on this.
Oh shit.
Did I get hit?
It's not letting me double trigger.
There we go.
Oh
no, I need to get into the combo.
Combo.
There we go.
Ah shit, shit, shit.
Oh no, no.
Ok.
Run away.
It's cool.
Two on this.
Oh shit.
It really sucks not having double jump there.
On this.
Honestly.
Oh
my god, all these lasers are gonna actually be the death of me.
We're so close.
We're so close, please.
Oh my god, we're so close.
Ah, bitch.
Leave me alone.
And
jump to avoid it.
Ahahaha.
Good job guys, we did it.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I love, I love being cool.
Thanks for the new strap, Minto.
I got you.
The Minto strap.
Just be minty fresh.
Minty cool.
Merry early Christmas.
Thanks Gordon Freeman.
Thank you so much.
Merry early Christmas.
I don't think Virgil cares.
You yap too much.
He just felt his pet die.
In his soul, he's like my little buddy.
Are they in hell?
Real?
Minto is the fresh maker.
Virgil, I didn't order a yappuccino.
Oh my gosh, I got S amount of orbs.
Dispida.
Sub to Mint, she is cool.
Nice.
So we are on mission 9.
Wait, I didn't see the 8.
In that last one.
I keep forgetting to look sometimes.
I keep forgetting to look.
Let's see, how long have I been at it?
How is the next mission looking?
Or is 8 in here?
Is 8 in this cutscene?
I can't remember.
I'm looking.
Oh, it will be 9.
So it's at the beginning cutscene, not the end cutscene?
Yeah, I did that.
Wait, is that the 9 with the eye?
No?
Oh, it's more obvious.
I thought I did something there.
I thought I was really like...
I cooked.
Cool.
Oh no, not this guy.
The actual clown.
Next stage.
He stinks like a lot worse, I'm telling you girl.
Oh!
Power couple.
Alright lady.
The party.
Missed it!
Dang it!
I missed the 9!
No, I saw the 9.
In my soul.
Well, I am a soul.
In my heart.
You are laughing too hard.
I was.
Christen the sorceress of the abyss with the blade.
Shouldn't I get to know her a little bit first?
Guys, how long do you think this one will take me?
Actually, no.
I think I can do it.
Let's go.
How much rorb do I have?
11,000.
Buy another plorb.
Boss hard, but weak to ice.
Save for plorb.
Can't be short, be a gamer.
Plorb equals DT, which also heals you.
I just want to keep buying this guy, because look at him.
This guy looks miserable.
I don't want to buy him.
I don't want to invite him.
I want to invite this guy.
He's ready to cause mischief.
Yeah, baby.
Okay, let's try it.
I... am nervous.
Because I can't go for too much longer.
I got some stuff I need to do.
But...
I will attempt.
If I can't finish it...
Within a reasonable amount of time, I will just save it for next time.
No worries.
Provisions, store room.
Wow, this room is...
I was going to say, this room is fancy.
Is this the lady?
Ladies?
Ladies, ladies.
Wait.
Oh my god, they're fast.
Got
got by the door.
Did I kill him?
Oh, they're babies!
Oh, they have little babies!
Oh my god, get away from the door, Dante!
Oh,
goodness.
Gary loves you.
Don't say that.
Ew.
No, no, no.
I knew she was going to do that.
She's all sexy on that wall.
And... there's little babies though.
Oh, oh god!
Gun?
Oh, true.
Oh wait, this one.
We did it.
Poor little babies.
What about me?
Aren't I your poor baby?
What is this?
It's a puzzle.
Poor little Minky.
Don't pity me.
Oh, no, I did not mean to do that.
Sorry, my hand slipped.
What is this?
Radiate the image sunken in the depths below to open a new path.
I'm guessing I have to do this once I...
Ok.
I'm guessing I have to figure out something and then...
The wheel resets it.
Stupid,
stupid game.
I can't handle my brain.
No.
No!
Do I need to go over there?
Where did you come from?
He showed me how to get there.
Anyway.
They are still trying, dummies.
What is this right here?
Ok, ok.
There is a door right in front of me.
What's in here?
God, no.
Please spare me.
Chew on this.
It's cool.
I got a white orb.
I got another.
It's cool.
Chew on this.
It's cool, isn't it?
Dante didn't care.
Try the...oh yeah, that's right.
What was theirs?
It's probably...wait.
Just kidding.
Stoil.
Hello?
Sword Master.
Oh, Crawler.
R-L-O.
If I spam it...
No talking.
Yeah, they're pretty noisy here.
They're pretty...they're saying a lot.
Okay.
They're...oh, not a lot.
Okay, just kidding.
I don't want to go in there quite yet.
I want to look around in here.
Orb.
Oh, hi.
They were just chill.
Not chill.
Wait, do they keep respawning because I'm bothering them now?
Oh no.
Did I mess up?
Wait.
Will it work if I leave?
What's in here?
Oh, I guess we'll find out.
A Devil Star!
I'll take it.
Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba.
I want to live.
Is
that a lady crossing her legs?
A relic of a...
A nude...a nude female is carved on the door.
Naked?
Oh la la.
It looks like something can be placed in the woman's hand.
Oh, I don't have that yet.
Okay, I came in here for no reason.
See ya.
Wait, what's over there?
How do I...how do I get to that spot?
Wait.
Do I need to chew on this?
It's cool.
How do I get to the door?
Oh, later.
Okay, I thought it was the thing that I needed to put in her hand.
That's why I was going towards it.
Okay, we'll leave.
Bye bye everybody.
Bye bye.
Oh,
they interact?
Wait.
Am I supposed to interact with these?
How am I supposed to know?
Don't act like I'm stupid.
I know I am, but...
How does she not know to interact with the glowing crystals that look like they would be...
that look like they would be breakables?
Destroy every destructible background object within the time limit.
Oh.
What is the best to do here?
What item?
It's just one of those days.
Oh no!
I'm only at 37!
What's the best...
What's the best weapon?
Maybe this one.
Let's try it.
I already feel faster.
It's all about the he says, she says bullshit.
I think you better quit letting shit slip.
I think you better quit talking that shit pun.
So come and get it.
I feel like shit.
My suggestion is to keep your distance.
Because right now I'm dangerous.
We've all felt like shit.
Where is the rest of it?
All those motherfuckers.
I only have three more.
Up top.
Go up top.
So close.
Oh my god.
Dante, I need you to run buddy.
I need you to do all these moves and like...
That's not as good as I thought it was.
There we go.
Faster, faster.
Faster Dante!
No, faster Dante!
I'm not gonna make it.
I feel
like we can do this though.
But he gets so slow when he like... I don't know.
No, no, no.
Turn around.
There we go.
Get up there.
Come on, come on.
Don't have time for styles.
Come on Dante!
We don't have time for styles.
There we go.
Wait, I'm missing one.
What am I missing?
What did I miss?
I missed a single bottle?
No way.
Oh my god, please.
Are you sure?
I'm still missing one.
I don't think it was a bottle.
I
don't know what I missed.
Maybe the taxidermy?
Let's try and see.
Where is the taxidermy?
Hold on, this is just the exploration round.
Oh, up there?
No.
What is it?
A barrel up by the deer's head.
I got those though.
No, I got those.
I missed a stool next to the table.
Oh, that!
That!
Oh my god, please.
Dante.
Oh my god, OK.
OK.
I wasted time.
Oh no, I'm not gonna make it.
Damn it.
Dante!
You bastard!
No, I still had three left!
What?
No, it's not the stool.
I still had three left!
I still have three left.
What?
No guys, I didn't have it.
There is only two barrels over here.
There is only two.
I wouldn't have had it.
It is the stool.
No, it's not.
I'm telling you.
I'm telling you, it's not.
See, I get the stool.
One of the barrels behind the slots was still alive.
I see, I see.
OK, this is my last time trying because I'm getting bored of it.
I'm getting bored.
Come on Dante!
Dante!
No!
I fucking hate you, you stupid ass!
You're so dumb Dante!
You're gonna make me lose!
Nevermind.
OK.
Leave.
Leave!
Barrel behind the bar.
We're not even gonna make it you guys.
Because Dante didn't wanna fucking jump up because he sucks.
At least I'm far... Actually, I'm getting a lot of robs from this.
It's kinda great.
I feel like... I feel like the Nunchucks should be hitting a lot more things than it does.
You know what I mean?
OK.
Nice!
Wall4 just taints your tiny little fragment.
Worst kept secret.
That's so funny.
Anyway, OK.
Now we can leave.
For real.
Subterranean lake.
I am the combat charge from the heavens.
Oh, charge from the heavens.
Charge from the heavens?
Oh, I don't think I got that weapon, did I?
Or is it...
Don't have it yet?
OK.
Well, I thought so.
Oh, I'm scared of falling into the water.
Or will it?
OK.
Large rifle that fires high penetration type bullets?
Wow, baby!
Is that my purple weapon?
Doesn't look very purple.
Not to you, huh?
With a little imagination it can be any color.
Whatever you please.
What's that song?
I can be brown, I can be blue, I can be violet skies, I can be pinto, I can be whatever you like.
Nice rorb stash.
A little bit of parkour.
OK.
Purple is an emotion.
What emotion does purple grant you?
OK.
I didn't need that, but you know what?
I just wanted to get it anyway.
Nice.
Freaky?
Makes you want to be freaky?
This is where we came in from, right?
So do I go through here?
I guess so.
I can't figure out how to get to this.
I don't think we can yet.
Circle door?
OK.
Let's go!
It's so...
What am I...
Holy shit.
It's crazy.
Wait.
OK, I'm back to fighting with my sword now.
Holy!
Oh my God, he's so awesome.
I love this gun.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Thank you.
Oh, with gunslinger?
Oh my God, you're so right.
I should have done it with the gunslinger.
OK, shiny thing.
Oh boy.
Oh.
Should have been me.
Not him.
Should have been me!
Come on spider wife.
Ambrosia.
Fruit that mankind is forbidden to even touch.
It is said to unlock the door to paradise.
Oh my God.
Oh jeez.
Are your little babies gonna come out?
The babies!
Can I shoot these things?
OK, not yet I suppose.
Hello ma'am.
Three?
What's my lucky day?
Oh, oh, oh.
Three or four?
Owie!
Oh my God, their teamwork on me is kind of crazy.
Let go of me!
Oh my God.
E
.T.
Oh you're so right.
Sorry, I forgot that I had it since I just got it.
Thanks for reminding me.
Yeah, you tried.
The
little babies.
Stupid babies.
OK, we got everything.
She forgot she has E.T.
I just got it, OK?
To be fair.
They just gave it to me.
Wait, I missed a gun?
No, I got...
Oh, you mean like I missed one?
Oh yeah, it's OK, I don't care.
It's OK.
Speaking of spider girls, thoughts on Black Arachnia from Beast Wars.
Oh, I love her, yeah.
But my favorite Beast Wars is always going to be Megatron.
Mid-star blasting and it was all over.
It was Artemis from a while back.
Oh, it's a laser gun.
Oh, that would have been cool.
It's all good though.
It's all good.
I'm going to do my little shortcut.
Oh, that wasn't a shortcut.
Anyway.
Anyway, bye bye.
Bye bye.
I have a naked... You don't understand.
It's so much more important.
Please.
Please, you don't understand.
She's waiting for me.
Use the ambrosia.
The door to paradise.
What's in paradise, you guys?
Sunken opera house.
Wait, is this the boss?
Is this the boss, that lady?
Yeah, it is.
I already don't want to leave.
Date, what are you... Date, what are you...
What?
No!
What was this game rated?
M or T?
I'm waiting to see what you do.
Emperor.
Oh my god, she has so many different attacks.
Holy cow.
Oh my god, they all hit hard.
She has so many attacks.
Is it... I'm getting... I'm definitely getting... There's blood, so I'm getting something.
But I'm not...
Oh wait, oh.
Her health bar is not going down at all.
I was just trying to get rid of... Someone said she has like a force field, but I was trying to get rid of it with a gun.
Oh shit.
A backfield.
Getting close is so dangerous though.
Oh.
I don't think I'll get it in this time because my health is so low.
But, you know.
We'll see.
She is tanky.
She's so tanky.
Oh, I...
She talks so much and I can't read her.
At least I'm getting health back.
What?
Oh my god.
That's so rude.
I just have to get the timing on it.
Alright,
so when she says, how's this?
She does... And then she does get ready.
She does a little twirl.
Oh god.
She sends her bats away.
Send your bats.
Get ready.
Oh my god.
Shit.
That one she just...
Okay, send your bats.
Okay.
What's she doing now?
She's laughing.
She's kind of cute.
Now she's circling.
Shit.
And she's going to shoot bats at me.
Leave!
Dante!
I like that the camera...
Oh no!
She's going to send the bats at me.
That one I... Oh my god.
What the hell?
Okay.
I will become tired.
And then she does a big, big zoom.
Big...
Uh oh.
Okay, I think she's about to...
What the hell is this?
Okay.
Alright.
Send a lot of bats at me.
Is she getting taller?
Or am I crazy?
Oh
my god.
I gotta get some health back.
Holy moly.
Become tired.
Could you please stop impersonating?
Dang, we got almost half way.
We got almost half way.
Oh, it was her boss name.
Oh it was the boss, Nevin.
Oh okay, it's her name.
Oh if I shoot, I float.
That is true.
That will be helpful for when the floor is lava.
Ah guys, I think I might call it here though.
Wait, if I stop here...
If I stop here...
Do I have to do the whole level again?
Yeah, I do.
Just leave it running.
I could.
I could just leave it running.
Do one more try and use Cerberus.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'll try Cerberus instead.
Might as well just finish her.
Yeah, I don't know how long that will take for me.
My eyes are starting to...
Here, you guys watch the cutscene.
Oh wait.
What can I do?
I'm really thirsty.
So I want to get water.
Do you think I can get water in the time when the cutscene is going?
Let's try!
Okay, you guys watch.
I'll be right back.
Now that's what I'm talking about.
I'm back!
Oh, I forgot to turn on my mic again.
But I was like, I'm back!
I was walking back into my room when I saw her say, then come on sugar.
And I was like...
Yeah, baby!
Hold on, let me take a sippy.
Actually, I also have to go to the little ghosties room, but I was like...
Someone also said to refill DT by shooting.
Oh, it is refilling.
Look at that.
What?
Your bats are kind of...
It's a bit slow.
Yeah, but it is an option, I think.
It is a good, like...
I think it's a good, like...
You know, if I just need to...
If I need to back off for a bit.
If I'm running low on...
On HP.
It could be good.
Hmm...
Sugar.
I miss having Stinger though, honestly.
Oh, there we go.
Wait, oh, I thought she was down.
Nevermind.
Stop!
She was down?
Then what happened?
What happened then?
I'm ready.
I don't think she was down.
I don't think I was that slow.
I wasn't that slow.
Oh well, it's okay.
We're still trying, baby.
Oh my god, I'm... Wow.
Wow.
Refill, refill, refill, refill.
What is she doing?
Oh, I think she's just like...
Laughing that I'm not doing damage.
Oh, nice!
Okay, we're doing good damage though.
We're doing good damage.
Fill up.
Fill up, fill up, fill up.
Oh my god.
She's like naked down there for real.
Nice, guys!
Oh, it's the...
Okay.
Now you will become tired.
Don't say I won't.
Now
you will become tired.
No, I won't.
Don't say I won't.
God, that one does big damage.
How's this?
Hammer, please.
Now you will become tired.
Don't say I won't.
I'm getting more DT, guys.
Alright, and...
Go in and...
No.
Shoot.
Big damage!
Nice, nice, nice.
Bats.
I'm so sleepy.
I'm tired.
I'm sleepy.
Become tired.
No, no, no, no.
Okay, nice.
You...
Nice.
Damn it.
I misread it.
Sugar.
And our health is not so bad, so...
Okay.
Alright.
Oh no.
Phase 2?
What is this?
What's happening?
She's becoming so tall.
She's become so tall!
Oh!
What's happening?
But
I was so wrong!
How dare you!
Okay.
Okay, I gotta regain some DT.
I may be able to be easier like this.
It'll be easier to actually, like...
Okay.
Oh shit.
Oh come on!
No, no!
Oh God, you guys.
Oh God.
My health, my health, my health.
I
don't think I have any items.
I don't think.
Let me check.
I don't think I have any though.
No.
I have a devil's...
This might not be a smart thing, but...
Oh my God.
Guys, that was the worst mistake.
Nevermind.
That was a horrible, horrible mistake.
That was a horrible mistake.
It was a horrible mistake!
No!
I'm so upset.
I'm too afraid to get close to her.
The kiss of death screwed me over!
Oh, that kiss of death really...
Oh, I was doing so well until then!
How do you avoid that?
I avoided it the first time, but I think I just like...
I think I just run away from her.
Oh, the kiss wasn't worth it.
Oh, DT breaks out.
Okay, good to know.
I'm so...
Angry!
Angry.
I'm just getting my DT, yo.
Can I button mash?
I was...
I was definitely button mashing, but...
Oh my God.
I didn't notice that she was sending...
Taunt gives you DT.
Is it working?
Come on, wimp!
Oh, it worked!
Oh my God!
Oh shit!
Nice.
Oh, not nice.
I got hit.
What are you doing?
Run!
In circles!
No.
Wow, DT... It gives a lot of DT.
That's kind of crazy.
Oh,
this is new.
Oh my God.
That one's new.
Interesting.
Damn.
How did I... How did I...
You know what?
That's fine.
Oh, I jumped!
I really did!
I jumped!
Oh my God, please.
Please.
Oh, I was on the stairs.
That's so funny.
Oh my God.
Okay, taunting...
Taunting only when she's not...
Go!
Okay.
Oh my God, ma'am, please.
I can...
Oh, come on!
No, no!
I'm not enjoying myself, ma'am.
Ma'am, I... I'm not enjoying my...
I'm not enjoying myself, actually.
Okay, I think it's time for kisses.
Kisses time.
Okay.
I'm trying to... There we go.
No.
Come on, wimp.
Oh, so the stairs are fine.
That's so fun.
Oh my God!
No, she went the opposite way from what I'm used to.
She went the opposite way.
Oh, no, no, no.
No, no!
She can't go up the stairs.
I found your weakness.
She can't!
Nevermind.
She can't go up the stairs.
She tricked me!
I let go though.
She can get hurt there.
Lightning in a bottle.
I also just realized the volume was up that whole time.
I'm so sorry, you guys.
You will.
You knew my father?
I got a twin brother too.
I fill your dark soul with light!
This
is insane.
There is no audience.
And the best part is he does this for no one.
Just himself.
There is no audience.
Nevan.
Dante can control bats by jamming in this curious guitar.
Oh, sorry.
No, I'm not jamming in.
Sorry.
Jamming on this curious guitar.
It's sickle attack is deadly.
I'm just...there we go.
Oh my god!
Wait.
There is a door on the other side.
This is a door?
Other side.
I see it.
Hey lady!
Are you ready?
That's a lady.
I love watching her fight.
The choreo in this game is like so crazy.
I must.
Welcome back.
Not.
Disbada.
Disbada!
Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky...
Thank you very much.
Minky gaming, excellent way to end the stream.
Let's rock!
Honestly.
We did it baby.
Thank you everybody who told me to use Cerberus.
We kicked her butt after that.
Ending the stream with a concert.
Let's save and...
I guess let's watch the cutscene for the next chapter and then we'll close it out.
I think we made alright progress today.
I love leaving with a cutscene and like a cliffhanger you know.
His own son.
It must be fate.
It's fun.
Every stream we get a new weapon which is pretty cool too.
Thanks for pushing me to complete this one because I'm glad that we got the new weapon.
Two new weapons.
Oh I guess technically yeah, the gun too.
Why is he so nasally?
His eyes bulging out.
Oh!
He is a baddy baddy.
That's why she hates devils.
What about you?
You're an incomplete being as well.
Both demon and human blood mingle in your veins.
Shut up.
Now that the final door is open, I have no use for you.
Is that really it?
He is dead dead?
That's it?
Mission 10.
The job.
Strengthen the silent bridge.
He got what he deserved.
And we never saw him again.
Oh this stage is boss.
You guys say that for every stage.
You didn't have enough motivation?
Froggy and Phantom together.
You guys have the same brain.
Has anyone died in this game from stab wounds?
That's so true.
I'm halfway through the game?
You're right.
I'm halfway through the game you guys.
I'm worried.
I feel like I'm gonna lose everything after I come back from Japan.
But I'm only gone for a week and a half so I think I'll pick it up.
I think I'll pick it up.
Not too bad when I come back.
But this was so much fun!
Thank you guys for the fun fun Devil May Cry stories.
It's just getting crazier and crazier.
I love these guys.
I love Dante so much.
That was fun, wasn't it?
What a cliffhanger.
I know.
Oh no!
Dante is such a goober.
He's so great.
He just does it for... I love this.
He was just jamming out for the love of it.
That's truly... We see Dante in his 100% purest form.
No cameras, no audience.
I mean there's us, but you know...
In his mind there's nobody around.
I love that for him.
Yumdum!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Virgil is also great.
He's...
I like that he's basically the Squidward of the game.
I have no use for you anymore.
We are Spongebob and Virgil is Squidward.
You sounded just like him.
Where's your motivation?
I'm gonna start using that anytime something upsets me.
Where's your... Or I'm challenging something.
Where's your motivation?
He's definitely a clarinet player.
Anyways guys, I really appreciate you watching.
It took three streams to get to this point, but the first stream was really short.
So maybe three more streams to finish.
We'll see.
We'll see, we'll see, we'll see.
And then we move on to Devil May Cry 4.
But we're still halfway.
We're still halfway.
Yeah.
Mint endurance phantom?
I could.
I could do an endurance.
And do two maybe.
Devil may take six streams.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Do it in two if you marathon.
Also depends on my gamer skills.
I always account for that.
But yeah.
DMC may be exhausting to endurance.
Really depends on how I'm feeling, honestly.
I think it's with that with any game though.
Some days I can play a game for seven hours easy peasy.
And some days I'm like, oh my gosh, I can only touch this game for three hours, two hours, you know.
It all depends.
But, felt good today.
I'm glad we got through so much.
Yeah.
Got through two in a jiffy.
I mean, I wouldn't say a jiffy, but...
I did just do it in one stream, so...
Depends on your motivation.
Otsumito everybody!
Thank you and I'll see you guys next time for more DMC.
Or whenever I see you next for another stream.
I appreciate you guys helping me out again today.
Thank you guys!
Merry Christmas Eve!
Bye bye!
Otsumito itterasshai!
Guys, I saved, right?
I did save, right?
I did save.
Did I save?
Did I save the game?
I'm scared to close out.
I did?
Okay.
Because obviously it won't let me save now that I'm in the mission.
Oh yeah, so I did save.
It won't let me save now that I'm in the mission.
Well, I guess I could start the mission.
And then save in the mission, right?
Yeah!
I'm just gonna save again.
Just in case.
Okay.
Okay, bye!